welcome to aj+ realtalk is Friday a lot
of big news stories happening around the
world let's get started I'm damu Bob I'm
Francesca I'm tired and I'm Dina we cut
a lot of new stories here this week but
the big story that's happening around
the world that everybody's talking about
is the shooting of the nine black people
in the church in Charleston South
Carolina
Deema you just got back to South
Carolina you were on the ground what do
you know what do you see I mean I saw a
lot it was really really powerful to be
there in that moment of time I arrived
on Saturday night I was able to get into
the church on Sunday mother Emmanuel
Church right when it opened its doors
for the first time and it was a powerful
experience I mean the emotions were so
raw there were tears all around but
there was also a lot of perseverance a
lot of gratitude for the unity that this
tragedy brought about I mean there were
people coming from all over the
countries they continued until we left
to leave flowers outside to pray for
Charleston I didn't sense a lot of anger
from the people I spoke to especially
the people who were directly connected
to the victims it seemed like it's it
was their faith in a lot of ways that
are helping them to move forward and
they would say things like God is
pushing us through God is guiding us and
if anything you know came from this
tragedy it's not these nine people
brought all of these people together and
I know that a lot of people weren't able
to go back just yet just because of how
heavy and how tragic it was that some
people couldn't make it out there some
people had to leave because they were
crying so much but overall it was very
moving ok cool and then what are you
after that so after that I mean one of
the things that we were really
interested in is talking about racism as
the whole entire country so me along
with my colleagues did a bit of a road
trip around South Carolina and we wanted
to ask folks is the South more racist
because we here in California and you
know in the lose your port on the South
Carolina it was my first time in South
Carolina so we started from Charleston
we drove all the way up to Columbia
where the capital is where the
Confederate flag is still flying you see
it flying I saw this I saw it was on
ground zero of the debates man and I did
hear some racist stuff there and I could
talk to you guys a little bit more about
that shooters well so we had arrived
right after there was a big
demonstration against the Confederate
flag and those people had mostly left
those protestors what remained was of a
handful or so of people who are out
there defending it and they articulated
their position I mean a lot of
we spoke to who are defenders of the
Confederate flag phrase it in terms of
you know this is our heritage this is
our history our grandfathers da you know
died fighting for that flag but when the
conversations extended beyond that
that's when the racism showed so one
dude for example was like they have the
flag here are they gonna take down the
african-american monument over there are
they cuz that's just for the Negroes and
if they're gonna take this flag down
then they gotta take that down another
guy straight up told me you know you
know what's racist the fact that they
have black churches and black schools I
said well that's because of segregation
he's like yeah and everyone got along
great during that time so to see that
those attitudes and those opinions
actually exist I don't know how many
people they represent but the fact that
they were able to tell me a brown woman
to my face with no qualms when I think
of South Carolina I mean a lot of my
friends were from the south they could
say you could you could taste the races
and you could feel it in the air I mean
you went to it like a shop to is what
guy saw another piece you put out there
where you went and saw that all the
different memorabilia tell me about that
I was crazy we went we went to edit we
went to a confederate flag store that
sells all sorts of merchandise from
bikinis to purses to sheets to whatever
this is about confederate flag became
anything you could dream up that you
want to own they have in a confederate
flag form i will say there was a lot of
paranoia in that store only one guy
would talk to us we asked we were asked
to leave in fact we were asked to leave
not even filming we weren't even allowed
to film on that strip mall every shop
owner from the tattoo place to the body
piercing place to the check in cash
place came out and said do not film here
we don't want this attention we don't
want controversy we don't want these
problems this is insane yeah so you know
the question I want to ask is if you see
the Confederate flag and I put up the
Nazi swastika flag after next to it what
would be your reaction you know I mean
like it's the same reaction at us and I
don't stand why the Civil War ended a
hundred and fifty years ago and we're
still pointing this flag I don't but I
will tell you Domino as we talk to
people on both sides those against the
flag will call it our symbol of hate and
you know racism and those who support it
and both brought up that's that example
of the of the swastika and the people
who are against the Confederate flag
said that you know look it's just like
this law sticker and those in support of
it say flags get abused and
Jews and their meanings get you know
misinterpreted and just like the
swastika so crazy really just missing
her just a big misinterpretation
all right Francesca you did a piece on
white supremacy and what I found really
interesting about your piece you
incorporated the CCC and obviously that
group has been you know donating a lot
of funds to current GOP presidential
candidates and like right I find that
really just strengthened and scary at
the same time tell me about that right
so we asked this question whether or not
white supremacy is fringe in the United
States or whether actually it has some
political momentum and so this is some
concrete money ties between white
supremacist organization the Council of
conservative citizens which you know
isn't the most out there but as like
former Supreme Court Justice Thurgood
Marshall called them sweet Uptown plan
they have sort of a more polished white
supremacy and Dylan roof was actually
inspired by them and some of their
thinking around segregation they were a
desegregated they also talked a lot
about black on white crime they talked
about you know sort of the raping of our
women and these things that Dylan
himself spewed before he opened fired
and it turns out that the CCC has
donated to GOP candidates not in this
current race but in previous years and
they've been around since desegregation
and so you got Mike Huckabee Santorum
Rand Paul Mitt Romney just the whole
gamut and those campaigns are now sort
of backtracking look let's go back you
know even if it was like a couple
thousand dollars though too much that
person I think anything I mean it can't
be associated with I mean if I if I'm
running for anything I'm by my side with
like the Nation of Islam where the Black
Panthers you'd be like really so
political room would be dead and this is
what we were talking about is that you
know how much does this sort of white
supremacist speech and just sort of
worldview influence our political
discourse
nationally and you can see that in some
of the Tea Party slogan and some of the
more like right wing of the Republican
Party but increasingly becoming more
comedy piece they take this they take
the talking points and they put bigger
better code words over it and it's kind
of its kind of what was out there I
don't want to I don't want to pinpoint a
particular news network but we know who
that news network is you know I so it is
what it is yeah Terry on the police
dashcam video I saw the police dashcam
video
I think of Tamir rice I think of Eric
Gardner you had your talk we talked
about a backstage talk to me man I mean
it's something that we've seen a lot
this year
ya know it's been in the news repeatedly
dashcam videos body cams too and it
never really ends well rice was the
calmest one I think I've ever seen
yeah this is a person who you know there
was a police call out this guy's armed
and dangerous he just shot nine people
in a church and it's like he on this
feeding well what it shows to me what it
shows thing that I watched that - Dan
because we were talking about it - as
well and you find it really eerie I
found it actually refreshing because to
me it says the police aren't actually
excellent at their job yeah and a man
just committed mass murder is armed and
dangerous and the cops not that many -
cuz it wasn't like 50 cops I mean right
if I J wat you'll have ten cops out here
in five seconds I guarantee you then
behave so well pull them out gently pull
them to the side
handcuff him arrest him and the store of
got my flash cards and that's exactly
what nobody else is that exactly when
aids aren't they mature like 9 million
yeah as a gun in the car there was no
like slamming her there was no none of
that liked like tough risk you know and
then you got a girl and then they like
parade him out first time they're not
wearing any handcuffs and in a in a
bulletproof vest it's almost like he's
yeah see what maybe my skin brother
I felt I what bothered me so much wasn't
that they didn't slam to the car
whatever whatever I thought of the young
girl from McKinney Texas I mean she's in
the bikini at a pool party with her high
school friends and she ends up getting
body slammed in the in and police need
in the back of her head unarmed nobody
bought her a whopper nobody mother a
whopper you there so you know just this
the difference between the two
uh-huh and we saw that in the comments
that's yeah the first things that people
reacted to two art pieces and even
online you there were tons of memes and
comparing the the poor girl in McKinney
to yeah Dylan roof and how do you think
she feels miss you said when she watches
that video of how he was brought in I
know my two cents the situation to get
back to you when I when I see when I
think of Charleston South Carolina I'm
burned by two things there's an 80s
there was an 87 year old woman that was
killed I would just have to I just hate
thing that she loved 87 years of her
life to get murdered in a church that
just bothers me for some reason just
really really but it could be my
grandmother and then number two I'm
looking at my five-year-old son and he
goes he says to me dad are we gonna get
killed if you go to church this Sunday
that's what Jack's me up like how do I
explain it to him like no we should we
should we should not be getting killed
at church I know so and I think we wrote
I think the real issue is Islam is
racism going to end absolutely not is it
gonna get better
we've had eight years of Obama it's
things seen have gotten worse and I mean
I'm not too concerned about their whole
races the thing my thing is this the
guns you know I mean I'm concerned about
just guns in churches not guns in
schools guns are everywhere and I think
that's what really needs to change and I
think Obama hit the nail on the head
like we are an event an advanced society
and these things don't happen
other events like these mass killings at
this frequency so I think that's and it
was so defeatist I mean you're just like
well but here's what I'll say it again
what the I don't think you can separate
the two I think gun guns are you just
you and I think recess because you're in
the combination of the two are beyond
beat both yes so that's what I got which
is are we are we wrapping it up or do
the to make some of the biggest stories
this week we're also and that we were
covering as well is that you know that
Americans are more likely to be hurt by
a white extremist than like Muslim
non-white extremist right and so that's
been
you know the stats are out there yeah
and yet here we are still talking about
Isis is coming for you Isis is coming
for you when in fact what about some
other races take this rethink national
security yeah that's Jon Stewart's point
he was like we got we got a little death
machine flying over five different
countries and then here in the states
you go to church you know me anyways
all right what do you have any rating
for next week well check out our peace
our aj+ on the road road trip up South
Carolina asking folks is the south
racist it's gonna there some character
the South races you know some people
said no some people said yes it seemed
like the younger people were more like
yes did you have like a clunk of your
racist
what are you doing we have an explainer
on tax evasion you featuring Buffy the
tax evader me and a blonde wig oh it's
slightly embarrassing but I hope our
audience will find it more entertaining
have to you is it a how-to on the brown
mood for the how to I don't get that
yeah yeah are you only trust blonde I
really talk about me personally I know
it was a attack says be a big
multinational corporations act again I
got my eye on Fitz I got my Irish yes
sorry okay I got my own Women's World
Cup I'm going for USA I will see how
they do this week and this weekend and
fingers crossed that hopefully the US
will bring it in no go China China in
there or oh yeah oh yeah I don't see
what happens like think USA USA all
right thank you guys keep it lock the
aj+ for more news videos and stories
look us up on Facebook Twitter YouTube
Instagram or download the app by
periscopes you guys later see you guys